you know do you know where all the names
came from
what names the names of the character
characters do you know where max comes
from
my grandma had a dog named max oh i
didn't know that you know where carmen
came from no cheech has a daughter named
carmen um do you know where ernie came
from no the real or i had a real friend
of mine oh i did know that one i didn't
know that angie came from ann that one i
know
yes right
and then
vic palmero came from a kid that i grew
up with named victor martinez but we
used palmeira because he was cuban yeah
all those you know all those had
like they were named after real people
right
hello everyone hola mis amigos you're
listening to oh my god hi
with me george lopez
okay let's do the show
i'm gonna go to that directly right here
neil sport sporting paul
you know george is oh i'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
george
george lopez oh my god omg omg bye oh my
god
it's holiday season you don't know what
to get a gift as a gift or stocking
stuffer well today's sponsor manscape
has the tools to guarantee you win this
year's stocking stuffer or white
elephant competition manscape is the
leader in men's below the waist grooming
and they have served more than 4 million
men
worldwide are you nuts
if i'm correct that's almost 8 million
balls that's 20 percent off plus free
shipping at manscape.com
o m g h i
your nuts will thank you
i need to have how much yeah just a
joint
joint a felony to have a joint
so
in
his head it's still a felony it was
weird it's the stigma yeah i know i i
remember and i never really smoked i
never really smoked a lot like i didn't
really smoke a lot of weed on occasion
but not even with all this stuff like
you know people thought got more weed at
the house at the party the weed party
everything she left you brought her
daughter the first year
she was there she was there
nine minutes i'm like we gotta go she
swam two a little bit huh
she swam a little bit what does that
smell like we gotta go
she swam a little bit and then she's
like porridge we're gonna take off i
said already yeah i mean it was like i
was like oh she goes she's a little girl
back i kept her outside and we were far
away from here but the more crowded it
got it started walking over and i was
like yeah it's time we go we gotta go
the contact high gets like why do i
always have to be outside
because i'm a good mom but yeah but you
know um
after that
show the one would be real i talked to
the sheriff
because i'm a supporter of alex and i
said hey i got a time i got to run this
by you know i just i'm doing this thing
with george
and
they had this guy be real
from crescent hill i think that's me
cyprus
right next to president trump the next
block
crescent hill started
saying discipleship [ __ ] it questioned
him
that's right it was right next door it
was the other side of the lumbar
and so and and i told him i was on the
show
and all they talked about the whole show
was about weed
and if you don't want me to associate
with you and you know
i'll still give you my i'll say i won't
mention and he said [ __ ] my morning
you don't work there anymore no not at
all no but i still i still support him i
do some inspiring stuff for him all
right i just said he said no not at all
he says it's legal now yeah you want to
talk as long as you're not talking about
illegal stuff i said no no no illegal
weed
no but i mean transportation you know
you have to get close lines oh is that i
think we're going around are we on yeah
if you don't want this on we started a
minute i start talking everybody falls
in line god damn it
it's just like the
and he didn't bother it didn't bother
him at all it doesn't bother me doesn't
bother him doesn't bother him so i don't
care so to me it's still like
like some do smoke in their house like i
don't i don't know that's not me you
know
again with that [ __ ] i thought i
turned off my gilly windjammer
i don't know how come you're wearing
that down or is it that name chad
pointed at your mouth are you back on
grindr again
no where was i are you back on grinder
you have that no no i was at some uh
let me see if they have a grinder at the
bottom down there i've stopped using
this address
no
i had to go to some pale sales pitch at
a timeshare
[Laughter]
because i get migraines and somebody
said well you know you might try some
cbd you might might try it and i
remember going down i got the doctors
you know you had to get a doctor's name
no but something really was wrong with
me and i went and i remember telling the
guy the doctor i cannot be high at all i
really need just just i don't want to be
high and he was looking at me like i was
the weirdest person that he'd seen
because everybody wants to get high and
then i went in there to the dispensary
and i walked in and i was like you girl
i was like this is so isn't this illegal
anymore
was it illegal
not then not then when i went
no
whenever they made the cbd oils and
stuff that became
they did that when they made weed legal
you could go buy for medicinal purposes
yeah but before we was legal there were
shops that were open yeah and they would
get raided and take all their stuff
there are shops that are not legal out
there
well i didn't go to those
i went to the good ones there you go not
permitted yeah yeah oh that's right you
got to pay your taxes man on your weed
how do they know if you have if you have
a permit or not it's not like
you just put up a green cross and people
yeah that's it i don't know since i
don't go to them you know that often i
went to one in lafleur the first one i
went in
and man they had it you had to wait over
here sit here fill up paperwork and then
they open up you go inside
and i was just looking all around man i
i felt ugly guys man these guys think i
must be a heavy doper
because i and i bought some ointment
that time
only after i consulted with my physician
who i will not name
and i asked that doctor the good doctor
or the bad one the good one okay that's
true he has a bad one bad dog that he's
had forever i told him no you'll be all
right my shortness of breath listen
that's fine
i'm a person with your age you can't see
out of one eye i don't think it's a big
deal yet you still got another one
that's good
that's why i assume about ointment and i
said hey is this why i meant any good he
said well let me tell you something he
says i buy it for my mother oh wow and
this is a doctor i trust with everything
oh that's good that's a good doctor yeah
he doesn't hesitate to tell any other
doctor to go [ __ ] themselves or anything
he's a doctor they use that kind of
language
i'm [ __ ] on my way
yeah the uh okay so so
i thought
if be real comes in here and and i did
their podcast i don't know what it's
called but
i was
oh wow and talking oh well you're always
talking be real tv
[Laughter]
that was the second time i had been with
george
and this guy be reels here and i'm
sitting there saying
they're going to talk about weed and
this guy looks like he's from the hood
you know he's a hood rat
and i said man what am i
what i'm going to say allegedly on the
hood right because you know i don't want
you to get in trouble with those guys
allegedly
and then they started talking about this
weed and what i found out was
be real was very articulate very nice
guy knew his business
very professional i mean
he talked about being from the
southern end of los angeles yes he
talked about the relationship between
him
lapd
and the sheriff's department and and it
was really
a nice uh
he also said something i didn't know
that they when they were on the streets
in the hood they never lied to the
sheriffs but they lied to the lapd yeah
it's because the sheriffs would
they said they had no respect for ellie
oh really i always thought it was the
other way around yeah that's what i said
yeah he said look well i know we got to
read on the police
i thought that was that was good
they were the guys that were tougher on
people oh i didn't think the lady said
he said they had respect for him he
didn't like him they
he said treat him respect him he said
certainly on both sides there's a bad
cop for the most part everybody
respected lapd they played games with
they didn't give a [ __ ] what they said
um because they were there they were in
the streets with them yeah and so it was
a very nice uh it turned me
180 degrees about my thoughts i mean
this guy when i pulled up
there was their escalade out there and
there was smoke coming out of both the
windows that it cracked like that they
didn't crack it all the way down like
hey let's get this smoke out here it was
just like that
on both sides like a house just starts
on fire
they call it there's a name for that
like like the hotbox
i'm a child of the 70s so i'm with gil
it definitely took a big time for me to
come but in here i thought if he
if he smokes in here he's going to walk
out yeah i thought did he he didn't
smoke no he didn't smoke in here
okay
is that coveted friendly
does pot kill coven
you know one thing i did hear a lot of
was like research about pot smokers like
not getting it as much because whenever
you're like you're taking a hit off a
bong and it's like killing whatever well
it's killing the bee like the virus in
your hair
everything
yeah let's get let's get cheech
so
he's he doesn't do this but
with this helps right yes yes
it helps i'll see well i learned um not
yours but now i'm going to try the
sanasana without the kolita the rana
right there's nothing
there's no polita that running there's
no there's no one there's five frogs
though so be careful that's a strange
thing oh really
but it's just the ones we've made are
all five it's tighter than the frogs
just cbd and hd
it is both so this this whole thing has
a thousand milligrams of th okay so i'm
going to have to be like a friday
no but i put it in my i put it in my
nose like when i was we were kids i
don't like vicks paper rub
i use it
for the new generation you see my finger
right here see how it's i broke that
years ago
and how did you break your circle
playing softball
took a hot chocolate third bait took off
how were you covered when you were
already in your 40s or what
this was before i was in my 40s though i
know old dudes out there you get hurt
ones that stays forever
i play sports all my life
you see all my fingers are straight over
here i broke [ __ ] jim kelly over here
the doctor the doctor messed me up all
right way behind which one did you go to
the good one
that's why i still had kaiser oh
and yeah and i i i probably didn't take
it and try to put on another one you put
you put a splint on it the wrong one i
looked at it i looked at the x-rays it
was broke right in the joint
i went to an autopsy doctor over there
says hey whatever your finger i said i
broke it he said really where i said it
broke right in the joint
he says we tell him he says go back tell
your doctor and i said he's going to get
pissed off at you
tell him you need to see an orthopedist
that thing needs surgery
and i said okay so i went back to see
the doctor my appointment and i said hey
doc i was talking to another doctor he
says that maybe this needs surgery see
an orthopedist and he got all pissed off
started just like the other dog said
he's gonna because you're not a doctor
he got all pissed off and i told him hey
chill brother you ain't gonna talk to me
like that you'll never see me again i
don't need your ass what kind of doctor
i i walked out
he says come back and see me in two
weeks i went back i went up to the
reception the [ __ ] doctor talks like
that to his patients yeah
that's what i said that's why i wouldn't
go back to him yeah they said okay he
wants you back two weeks i said you can
scare me whatever you want but she'll
never i'll never see him again right so
they said okay we're gonna get an
appointment in a week
with a female doctor i said okay so i go
in there she were talking she put the
x-rays up there and the first thing is
training day
okay all right okay
okay denzel
and she looked at the x-rays she says oh
no you need to see an orthopedist that
needs surgery
and i said thank you so go back to
reception i wanted a guy pizza hut say
yeah
you're been everywhere
so when i saw the doctor with the
orthopedist he says oh yeah he says you
should come here right away it needs
surgery he says i can operate on right
now he says but because it's already
healed so much you're gonna crack it
you'll break it i can't guarantee that
it'll ever go straight again you know
you've got it there so if you can live
with the cricket finger
was it a ground ball you went to get
like that hit your finger thank you all
right yeah i learned i got a broken
finger no amina oh my my reading oh
right there how did you do that i broke
it chasing my little brother and he made
me mad and i was like where'd you grab
him i grabbed his shirt and he ran and
twisted and do like some tricky move and
it took my finger with me and you know
we were like old school was like oh yeah
i can move it i'm fine and then
crooked finger wow yeah yeah
so now i've got arthritis in there and
now every once it just starts hurting it
aches oh that's not good
that stuff works yes it does oh that's
awesome
no okay look at that i'm not worried
about the fight that's the only place i
put her can you stop talking about being
high
that's right he's trying to get
everybody high all right let's stop
saying how you gonna talk about all of
this stuff you said be careful it has
five treasures
high 20 times
and but if it's not making kill high
then i will be okay i think you'll be
all right all right but but let's say
this let's transition to this okay as a
dancer yes a lot of people don't know i
want to take everybody through your
career okay
as a dancer
all dancers i'm pretty sure have aches
and pains from dancing yes and you
probably feel those
in the morning and at night when you get
up all the time your hips your knees
knees neck back yes go through it i have
a 27 year old granddaughter that out of
high school got a
scholarship to a school of performing
arts she is
sang and danced all around the world
okay and she's now 27 years old
maybe 28
and everything's good
that's good is she within that group up
for people because they're the ones that
grind all the kids when they're out on
tour yeah she's she
i don't know what the hell what
better help with people no i don't know
do you remember they were like a touring
group
they're all boating each other
she did the same thing it was a group
like that
without the bony people
my granddaughter was doing this
allegedly
okay but wait i can't say for sure
because i got rejected because i was a
street dancer and there was no classes
there was no hip-hop classes back in the
day they would literally find you in a
club paul abdul and janet jackson used
to come down to the club and watch our
moves and copy those i mean it was
really born in the streets and we didn't
know how to protect ourselves literally
i'm dancing on cardboard on concrete in
venice beach passing the hat for change
concrete is no fun to put your knees on
put your ankles on and all that so yeah
i didn't know you did that i know you
danced it oh yeah i used to go around la
and enter dance contests to make money i
did i needed money so you'd win dance
contests in orange county you'd go as
far as you possible as your gas would
take you and my pinto and uh we would go
down there and and and make money who
did that you and your friends from
school or junior high or oh no no these
are these were my friends from the club
i was dancing with some of them were
crips like casey was it skeeter rabbit
he was he would dance all these
different people that's what she teaches
hip-hop now yeah now there's classes now
you know how to take care of yourself
she teaches
hip-hop yeah and she's still there she
performs with a group uh i just
go do whatever you guys do
i have no idea
how you're going to concern them
i don't big groups any more than bone
each other make sure it's not up with
people that don't have sex in our group
when i was dancing i didn't have sex
with any of them they were dogs those
guys okay so
all of them what was your first
time you got hired as a dancer
first time i got hired as a dean did you
do commercials i know you did videos i
did music videos so i guess one of my
very first music videos was a prince
video all right yeah i mean i've been in
melinda carlisle prince cher
okay what was prince prince
he did an instrumental jazz album called
mad house six and i've never even heard
it like i think it's like way in the
vault and every there was only six songs
and it was one two three four five six
and i was in number three i think and it
was shot in this vintage theater in dan
downtown l.a and it was like this
cabaret style my friend cat was you
remember the theater was in the ace
earning the opportunity oh no it was so
so run down i mean it was like scary we
were going probably
it was but it was really good
for a while yeah so anyway yeah prince
he uh he was just
so weird he would just sit in the middle
of the theater
and
watch us
dance with no expression like kind of
mean and i was like are we sucking or is
it what's happening here but yeah i was
in his his video so you so he was
actually physically there oh yeah wow
with his little cane and his high heels
looking all princey
with that tiny little voice he had it
wasn't in the morning though it was
probably in the afternoon oh it's all
day shoot all day oh they shoot yeah and
there's i mean it was interesting is
there went uh there was a metamorphosis
in my career i started you know like
hip-hop and all that you didn't have to
dress all sexy or whatever david bowie
when i was on tour with him i didn't
have to be like super sexy but as
you know the 80s 90s happened my
costumes got smaller and smaller and i
did
a music video for the house of lords
do you know them
michael bay directed their video oh [ __ ]
yeah but anyway they were like holding
up these costumes it was like a bikini
and some gloves with long fringe and i
was like okay i need to stop this
because it's getting really did it go
that way it went that way right yeah
yeah and i had to stop and then um
david how did you did you audition for
david point yeah tony basil is the one
who you know tony bezos oh mickey you're
so fine you're supposed to oh yeah
everybody knows tony from that and now
you see that video i thought those girls
were fine and now if you look at those
videos on youtube it's all about them
being overweight and chunky oh really i
don't even recognize they look like
regular see that's awesome
he's like let me google that regular
little thing body positive tony basil oh
mickey
she just had that that was a great video
too so tony basil was like like ground
breaking she was in the underground
break dancing scene she was a locker and
a popper that's what she did and she
knew all of us and i guess she worked
with david bowie before choreographing
one of his videos so she
picked dancers from the club and had
there's like a hundred of us that she
ended up getting together and we had to
have this crazy audition where you would
you'd you'd dance because they couldn't
really choreograph you because everybody
just had their own style so she would
literally you bring in your mixtape or
whatever sound and you put it in your
boom box and then hit play and then you
would go for five minutes freestyle
whatever you need for everything and
then stop and then
um we had to like fall asl drag a
blanket and a pillow and fall asleep on
the wall it was weird because it was you
know david bowie's kind of avant-garde
and you had to be willing to take the
journey and so out of all those dancers
that ended up being five of us who
toured the world with him and then you
toured right wow so did you tour
you you went commercial or by bus game
we had a private jet
yes he has peter frampton david bowie
private jet i went from living in a
single apartment in a crack neighborhood
in hollywood on wilcox right off
hollywood boulevard um and working in a
50s diner that's why i woke up
i thought your skin looked good
okay that's a different craft anyway um
yeah and i worked in a 50s diner and
cleaned my carburetor on my pinto every
morning because my car was all jacked up
and it wouldn't run unless i did that so
i went from that life to touring around
the world first class in a private jet
with david bowie and peter brampton wow
and i was like yo damn the world is big
i want a big life you know when i met
princess diana and i met bonnie i'll
never let my granddaughter watch just
watch his podcast because she'll want to
know she's gonna say they're still hope
they're still oh yeah uh well you know
honestly i don't really i was anymore
think i mean it's not as the production
is not what the production was back then
i think well kovid killed everybody and
everything so um i think they are um
they get their dancers and then they
take them around the world with them but
it's weird is it cyclical like sometimes
music videos are just you know it's
billy eilish thoughtfully you know
singing quietly and then
you know it will come a time where like
backstreet boys or somebody like that
where there's all this dancing
it's it's cyclical yeah you know peter
frampton too um yeah so they were
separate tours all right no pete was our
lead guitar player oh peter was in the
band yeah oh that's incredible yeah i
have a picture of peter frampton and
we're in nice and um i'm holding him i'm
like carrying him down the hallway in
the stadium that we're playing it was
like can we see that picture when we put
it up see if i can find it no not now
but maybe she'll get it get it to us
yeah now i'm like cooking uh rick
glassman over here pausing that cut i'd
go
charlie sexton duran duran they opened
for us in canada you know hanging out
with simon leblanc
it was so crazy yeah it changed my life
it really did and did you know david
boyd did you let me let you guys talk to
him and all that stuff oh yeah he was
you know we're all hanging out i mean uh
he was super nice super brilliant super
shy but he was you know we had to like
manhandle him during certain parts of
the choreography so we were hanging out
in new york at sir studios for a month
rehearsing and then in rotterdam in
holland you know
doing choreography i'm impressed by that
so like i've known you a long time i
didn't know that you didn't i know you
danced but i never really asked you
if you you never cared about me george
just a typical husband narcissist
doesn't care about his wife constant
goes on my mom rushed more of women in
my life
my grandmother mayan
and
sandra boleta and constance
that's so sweet
thank you for putting me up there yeah
on the mount rushmore and you know how i
feel about a couple of those on that
list so you would move up
wouldn't that be crazy if you could
actually that would be george lopez give
his kidney back i understand that i
maybe and not in my lifetime but
understand that they are
making kidneys
they put a pig's kidney into
a person and it didn't reject because
they were using medicine on both of them
that were similar
and that they are working on a chip
to put in your body that becomes the
kidney what that's what you told me
about how they're going to do that but
my doctor is it the printer that you
know how they have that 3d printer where
like like printing organs or something i
don't know about that one but they're
they're got big advances like wow and
not in this generation but a couple
generations yeah there's october 20th is
the article where they talk about the
genetically altered uh pig kidney going
into a human that's crazy can you
imagine being the first dude
so all those girls you danced with
before they put the lights up are back
in play
you know i'm very happy i have uh my
daughter who turns 50 tomorrow
on the 21st of december
uh shout out to her she's given up one
of her kidneys for
my sister's daughter one of my nieces
wow that's
huge here 24. yeah and and i i couldn't
be prouder i remember you when you got
yourself i'm going to give you some
advice
tell her not to give it up they don't
like donors to meet
usually in the kidney
they grew up together because eventually
one of them is going to say
you know my van didn't start today you
think you can buy me a van i'm not
buying you a man oh but i gave you a
kidney you won't buy me a van
oh like the debt like there's a debt
that they have to pay if they know each
other not family but yeah an issue
becomes in fact i heard that it can
become an issue in families
i've asked around a lot
rumor word on the street but uh you know
i don't know i got mine out there she
wouldn't even tell
the family she did that in the show
where she goes uh what if he needs a kid
to go why you came back i got four grown
ups
yeah she didn't tell anybody in the
family my niece's mother nobody on her
side nobody knew up until about two
weeks ago when they got the final date
at the 21st oh wow then she finally said
okay this is what we're doing
when i found out i need a kidney i went
to cedars and i was in this doctor's
office and
he says
you found a donor i think
anne was probably not yet but the guy
says he wasn't going to try history he
was a guy came in here and had his
family all around him his wife his kids
grandkids around him they were kind of
grown and you know he wanted the news
delivered to his family
and they said you know you're going to
need a kidney or something from kidney
function she goes but maybe somebody in
your family want to be tested and he
said all of my like
you know how they do like wow
all of them
all of them did the old like oh look at
the time we better get out of here
and he said i don't know he goes did
they test you but so far none of them
stepped forward but even to get tested
not a match just for you just to get
down you wouldn't even test i wouldn't
even get that oh that's messed up that's
your family there you go that's that's
not one of our christmas lists just got
a lot shorter
my my buddy that i talked about last
time
has a candidate i remember yeah yeah
he has cancer
salazar on the last episode we had i i
mentioned his name
and he sat there and he's got you know
he's up in age like i am and he's got a
female friend that's also up in age and
she told him
because he's got us one of the spots of
cancer is on his kidney
and she said hey i'll donate a kidney
i'll i'll give you one of my kidneys and
he just looked there he said well if you
don't mind nothing personally but i'd
like to get one from somebody a lot
younger than you
oh no
how long did they last after that oh
they still aren't ralph's crazy
she's used to it yes she doesn't mind
have you ever been to stephen's
steakhouse
around the world not her dad amsterdam
paris you don't know what you've missed
i've been a vegetarian for 40 years
a good friend of mine's a
vegetarian vegan or vegetarian no
vegetarian okay are you a vegetarian i'm
veganish now
and he went there and there was a bunch
of meat everything there they fixed him
a vegetarian plate and he says it's the
best vegetarian plate i've ever had it
was filled with lard
steven steakhouse is not a sponsor where
is it has not received any money
[Music]
naughty or nice tis the season to
perform manscape best-selling product is
the performance package 4-0 which is at
the top of every man's wish list this
year inside you'll find the lawnmower
body trimmer the best trimmer on the
market for your balls
butt and body and the weed whacker ear
and nose trimmer now these are our picks
for manscape surefire win stocking
stuffers
the manscape
two-in-one shampoo and conditioner
just launched kill two birds with one
stone the manscape cologne infused body
wash
shears 2-0 luxury 4-piece nail kit crop
mops ball wipes for the stanky balls
manscape signature cologne these
formulation are all vegan
cruelty free dye free
sulfate free and paraben free to show
you
their products are legit are you nuts
make sure you hurry up to ensure that
these gifts will show up before the
holiday season begins and while you're
at it get 20 off and free shipping at
manscape.com
omghi
[Music]
get 20 off and free shipping at
manscape.com
omghi be the ballsiest gift this year
with manscape
culves next year
kulos to come was my first book was the
first book i wrote the george lopez
story
well they're going to say oh so
constance you know
um
vegan then at vegetarian when we shot i
was vegetarian and she and listen
at a show especially our show there was
a lot of stuff to eat a lot of mexican
food a lot of tamales
candies and all but every day we had a
great craft service where you get the
food
and mary i know she
hardly ever cheated maybe once or twice
or no but every once or twice what she
did i happen to just wander and catch
her all the time i used to catch her all
the time and she had a cup of uh tea
with soy milk and then another thing and
i go what's in there don't look it's
like a little like doughnut holes or
something like that that was krispy
kremes every single day and i had a
strategy okay public humiliation worked
for me i would go
in front of everybody because there was
always people around there i would grab
a krispy kreme and i would start walking
to the trash can and i would take one
big old bite and as i'm chewing chuck it
in the trash can and i knew i couldn't
grab another one because people would be
like oh look at her all wasteful so i
wouldn't grab another one but i did get
my one bite of the krispy kreme yeah so
that's what you always saw
that's right that i stood away from
that's how i maintained my girlish
figure
hey man you're not in hd hd tv sucks
remember when they told us we were going
to hd on the show and everybody you know
we went from like video to hd and all
the women were like no
[Laughter]
i thought that be careful man my shoes
all of a sudden made that it made the
screen go like that yeah yeah we were
shorter and wider so my shoes got higher
because that way i was taller so i
looked slimmer oh i had it all strategy
i had it down crazy
the uh
good
good so uh again okay so also classic
i'm not sure if people know
the the vinyls
i had a big hit with i touched myself
it's called that touch mice remember
that video
directed by michael bay
another one oh he did that he and i
worked together several so michael bay
was a directed music he was a music
video i know commercials i did sprite
commercial with him as well sprite and
toyota
wow i did a lot of things with michael
bay what did you think about that the
vinyl store they didn't take their
dancers on tour with them did they no no
no we just auditioned for the video it
was michael bay was so awesome at least
for me because he would hire these
models these models but then they
couldn't move right so i was always
cute enough to be in there but you know
i was the movement i was the dance girl
so like he would have dresses made for
me so i would spin and you know he had
it storyboarded out to where whenever it
got too boring they'd throw constants in
there and make her spin or make her
dance or make her do something that was
a big song yeah
it won an mtb
mtv music video oh did it really
unfortunately that singer i believe has
passed
yeah but they were they did the us
festival the vinyls back
in the day in like the 80s of the they
did yeah
the i'm in awe because all the stuff
you're talking about what she's done and
toured and traveled and who and how
professional and we haven't even gotten
to acting yet no
i think it's a big deal
with as a dancer because you're touring
with two
musicians i mean then yeah you're
performing in front of one of the 80 000
people
on stage yeah and the best part well
for me yell back to your transition is
like i failed drama in high school like
straight up f
and it was because i was too shy i
couldn't talk in front of anybody like
when we did the the mime stuff and all
that i had a nice hard b and then when
we had to speak and do monologues i
couldn't memorize lines
i couldn't memorize lines and i was too
shy to speak in front of anybody so then
i was like okay fine i just won't talk
in front of people i'll just make a
career as a dancer but then after doing
it for so long
i started i helped you guys i
transitioned i got a little more
comfortable and then i could actually
speak in front of people did you go to
acting coach or yes for seven years who
was that you can you say larry moss he's
amazing he's a he directs broadway he
directs some movies he's just brilliant
human and uh wow
let's cut to let's go through the
casting process of george
of celina oh selena um
like how did you hear about it
because you know that you've seen selena
right she does the washing machine dance
oh i didn't i i did the washing machine
dancing in that movie again
jennifer lopez's mother which i think
yeah they're the same age yeah well
she's uh three years younger than i am
yeah okay i can see a latina
with a 50 year old
old yeah no i i got that opportunity
because i worked with gregory nava
the director writer of it um because i
did a movie called my family me familia
which is my very first that was before
yeah that was your first movie it was my
first movie and um
because i had worked on that with him i
got an opportunity to screen test to
actually play selena there was i think
ten of us nine of us that you remember
who the other ones were uh jennifer
myself uh i think sadie lopez and then
there was others this young girl from
texas that looked exactly like selena
but she was like 18 years old and she
just was a little green she wasn't but
in the pictures
she was magnificent um there was a
couple of uh the other girls that got
opportunities and so
i screen tested you know the hair the
makeup the bitty bitty bum bum we had to
lip sync we had to do everything and
then um
i didn't get it yeah because you could
dance
so he he the same phone call
you know he said you know
i want to go over some stuff would you
come
meet with me and i met with him and he
said unfortunately it's not going to go
much further for the role of selena okay
so we've got somebody else for that but
would you
consider
reading for the role of the mother
and i thought
uh
okay my rent is still due i got to make
money so sure why not and i read it and
it was because back then you know there
was all this privacy stuff because it
was shot the like
within the year where selena died so the
script was bright red like the color of
this and i read the script because they
did that so you couldn't copy it
so i read the script
and i realized no matter how old you are
your mom still thinks you're her little
baby and so i thought you know
it doesn't matter how old she is i could
play her mother and half the movie was
her flashbacks when she was younger so i
thought you know i'll try i'll do this
and i love him i love the story i wanted
to help help selena's dream happen and
also i didn't know about selena until i
actually auditioned for it and i had to
do all this research so once i
discovered her
um her story and who she was
i really wanted to be a part of it so
they brought in an aging crew and from
my screen test like there was other
actresses who screen tested that were
more age-appropriate
and um i thought you know
what what's going to happen they're
going to tell me no who would they have
like rosanna desoto um they uh the other
one jimmy smith's uh
girlfriend
yeah wanda dejesus i think she was there
um and so you know they did like a crew
like lace wigs for me and they aged me
because they had aged me in a movie that
movie i did before my my family me
familia so they aged me and they just
slapped some fat padding on me and i did
it i think it worked if you get the cast
i looked older than edward james almost
in real life
or did you yes
they made me listen i never realized
that she was in the movie i've seen the
movie that month
you don't remember me in the movie no
i really don't because all i do is too
much cbd and too much
i think
you don't drink beer i think no i don't
but gills
all i did was i focused on selena gil
i'm in the movie selena and the lady
that killed her
oh yeah yeah
played that role that was a really hard
role
and
lupian tavares was
one of the funniest people ever yes yes
yes i can imagine if she was here the
two of you together would be fire wasn't
upset with me because
i didn't because everybody thought
that lupian deveras would play the
mother in my show oh really
yes
and i said no
because i thought she was in everything
that latinos did and that for an instant
if you're the same person
and like no eg that cholo that's in all
the movies right right that you become
like that and i said i wanted the show
to be more
of
not somebody you had seen but somebody
that could really play i mean she would
i think she would have been good at it i
don't think she would have been as good
as goleta no i don't i agree because you
have seen her be the mean mom before and
she was lovable and adorable but you're
right it would have been an incarnation
a new incarnation of something she's
done before the leader was uh she came
in we couldn't find anybody to play the
mother part and uh
i think they sent in like women would
have like a donald duck hat and they
were all in different countries in
mexico or they did you know after
[ __ ] mexico to try this [ __ ] guy's
stupid ass so i go you gotta find
somebody in here man like the [ __ ] you
doing over the brazil i'm back
from brazil yeah so they were like all
the ladies would do a thing where
there'd be a window right there feet
walking by like right wherever
and then uh a basement apartment shooter
was retired yeah and her husband you
know joel was an agent and he brought
the script back and he says listen i
know you don't work but
you should read this and she read and
she's like what is this it goes oh
they're trying to find the mod i can't
find a mom
so she came in there with her little
long skirt and her leggings and her
tortoise glasses and a little bag oh
that's right she was super chic right
yeah and uh she came in and she took the
thing she turned around and she read it
she was mean she was funny
she came in all happy hi everybody
everybody and yeah yeah she got her
stuff and she walked out and they looked
at me and they go what do you think
i said man um
and they go come on i go i think wait
you asked me what i thought i said just
ask her if she's like that happy every
day
because that would [ __ ] kill me
and it didn't it did
not and then around the holidays she
would get
she would we call her evil elf she would
turn evil yeah she would get mad at
everything that's because we were all
trying to arrange all of our holiday
things the best presents the most the
parties we come on and they told me uh
the day her son went away to college she
goes somebody came over and said you
know
belitas uh someone to college it's very
emotional too so i sat down almost i go
so where's matthew probably in the air
right now
the sensitivity yeah she laughed i mean
yeah we got along we still do yeah we
got along incredibly incredibly man
so uh but then you know we had her and
then
you remember we went and did
first of all they were i'm not going to
say the name of the other actions they
were two i've never told this story
before okay i told them the golf course
one thing i've told them
there was two
last actresses for the part
of angie
okay and
one was constance and one was somebody
who
no offense concerts was a little more
voluptuous yes
word on the street is that she was on
caliente
and lopez
my ex-wife
said to me
why are you [ __ ] around with that
other girl why because she has big tits
she probably has you in there all three
of you guys wrapped around her finger i
said you don't even know what you're
talking about you're not over there and
she had all three of those wrapped
around
but that's not going to get you the part
yeah and we did wardrobe one day where
they came in and had them try on you
know stuff and
awful
and and
not appropriate i would think these days
but
it was clear that
even i was like
yeah we got to go with concerts and then
yeah but after seven times
i auditioned seven times and then we did
it hold on two times they said no thank
you very much it's not gonna go further
with you and i was like you know what
when they came back the sixth time i was
like
can i cuss yeah i [ __ ] dare you
to not give me this job i will come back
i'll be i'm like i'll be relentless i
will come back every single time and
i'll make you tell me no because this is
my job that other girl was was
not as funny as constance and not as
good an actress as constance and but hi
so hot do you remember the screen test
we did yes
i do
wait can i just tell you when i showed
up on the drew carey stage and i went
into me i was like oh this is legit
we drew carey was still in the air so
we're not on the air so we have to go do
a screen i have to do a screen test with
constance and we don't have a stage or
anything to show
we're still casting and we did it and
used
uh that would be a great video to get oh
my god we use drew carey's kitchen yeah
and living room and do our our screen
test see and i was surprised because i
had already tested once before and then
they told me no wasn't going to work and
they said oh we're going to test again
but i didn't realize i was actually
screen testing
with hair and makeup
the craziest part was everyone
was so nice to me like
crazy falling over themselves i was like
wow
some other actress must have tanked this
really bad if they're being so nice to
me because they were like fans of mine
and i you know and i wasn't you know
that big time we didn't do a screen uh
a test for an eye it's just me and you i
don't know
i'm not gonna say anything else but that
wasn't a screen test
they never left the room
and anywho they were very nice to me and
i remember
the craziest part is when we were when
we moved from the kitchen to the living
room
i had done these scenes
so many times that when we did it and i
called carmen
and i looked and some actress came down
it startled me
i was like oh [ __ ] there's somebody
really here that was a monster it was
moss it was yes
marciello lucia's like mom i'm like oh
[ __ ] hi honey was louie there too no it
was just moss
yeah
and then there was a line in there about
oh if i'm going to kill her she's going
to be awake
[Laughter]
i looked over at her and i go i think
you got yourself a job
and she goes how do you know
because the name is george
i've got some swim that was awesome i
still had the bitterness of the seven
times coming seven times
i don't you know i never got that i
think maybe they stayed because i said
or we said eventually like what are we
doing with her
we can't let her go kind of i mean
there's nobody else i mean it could have
been her
no i think i think they they they
you know there's the protocol like if
you really they're trying to protect my
feelings like if it's really not gonna
go no matter who else you've got going
on they'll cut me loose because i was
shooting american family on pbs and i
was doing two shows at the same well
when i got george lopez i ended up doing
two shows at the same time for two years
but was he upset that you would yeah oh
yeah oh yeah
he's not i don't know i've never seen
him in a long time like me
who uh gregory nava he doesn't oh oh i
didn't know that i went to el paso for
the memorial and i took all the
people from the um
the event to a mexican restaurant and he
sat there and ate there and i paid never
said hello never said thank you well he
is socially he is socially awkward i
will tell you that
but um i didn't know well
can i can i explain from his point of
view you know that i have something to
say and i will not say even though i
know we can cut it out i'm not going to
say so
seven times
that man had to shoot me out to get me
free so i could make it to george lopez
and this is no idea yeah he had to shoot
me out and
i i guess i guess make her go first on
the whatever day it is
everything's adjusted so she can do all
her stuff and and be gone like doing two
and your break in the afternoon and it's
a single camera show right and it was it
was brutal so
the reason it was a little hard for him
was because
um we had signed in our contract that we
wouldn't do any other predominantly
latin show
and my manager was so smart he said he
just put one hour in there oh
and because he put one hour i could do a
half hour show he did that yeah my
manager is genius and i'm still with him
to this day because i think about that i
didn't know that he would not have had
don't you i maybe
he didn't
i'm sure that's why but yeah well no
also porch uh when we premiered this is
also something that's bad
or hard or difficult or tricky of course
it happens with me
um
american family and george lopez were on
the air on the same night
at almost the same time
so there's they started at 8 15
and we started at eight
when we first came out or was what was
our first time slot nine
so whatever it was is i was competing
with myself for 15 minutes and they er
edward james almost was pissed ask him
about it i've never told this story i
hope i'm not getting anybody interested
in the show though no no no but eddie
you know it was like that was like the
first latino family
yeah
my wife yeah yeah well oh no i was his
daughter on that i do my daughter i was
his wife on selena was his daughter on
american family and then um
yeah
and then
we started to do the show yeah
uh what do you remember about
the beginning of of it
like was it fun for you
was there any
things you didn't like or
i mean it's all pretty well written
right you know do you know where all the
names came from
what names the names of the characters
do you know where max comes from
my grandma had a dog nick max oh i
didn't know that you know where carmen
came from no cheech has a daughter named
carmen um do you know where ernie came
from the real or had a real funny
america oh i did know that one i didn't
know that angie came from ann that one i
know
yes right and then
vic palmero came from a kid that i grew
up with named victor martinez but we
used palmeira because he was cuban yeah
all those you know all those had
like they were named after real people
right
i didn't i didn't know i knew ernie
and i knew anne because andy
what's ernie doing today is he still
acting or he probably weighed about 75
pounds and he's like yeah he's defending
projects he is so
slim he has slammed down like crazy he
went
vegan yeah i think so something like
that really yeah i didn't know that see
i didn't know the history of the names
at all in the beginning the show was
hard for me because i had had uh limited
experience on sitcoms i mean i did
michael j fox sitcom i can't remember
what that one was that he'd shot in new
york spin city yeah spin city at
and a couple other things
and then um it was actually one of my
and then i did union square so this is
like the only third sitcom that i had
done
and um
switching from drama to comedy is hard
so i remember because remember once i
got
george lopez
the show not you uh the show i had to
shoot five days of drama
or no i was shot us
and then i would on the weekend like on
a saturday and and i would go switch to
drama and so they were they would say
that oh you've been on the show again
because i would be really funny on the
drama and then it would come back i
remember some of the original episodes
when i would get mad at you i'd get
really mad like serious and so that's
what i tried to tell you
he's like he's like yeah take it just
take it down
remember you think he's funny yeah yeah
you like him
um i didn't know you shot on the
weekends yeah
yeah they accommodated you a lot i had
no idea or our show a lot yeah yeah
that's what was the shooting schedule
like for for your guys show monday
through friday
friday friday and then started rehearsal
monday tuesday but then didn't we switch
to thursday no
i feel like we did because i remember we
shot on thursday club uf we'd hang out
and then the next morning we couldn't
hang out because we had to get up early
and memorize things i think we might
have switched switched it once no maybe
once or twice yeah yeah i hated when we
did that
it was fun man i mean the live audiences
that would come and see the show it was
the best
pretty amazing yeah it was good always
really uh supportive and loud it was a
good show well they were so happy i mean
it would in 75 years of television
history to ever make it past 13 episodes
yep
this is the first one
you know that's that's desi arnaz there
was a big old space between denzel ernez
and us yeah so that's big
where'd you guys tape
warner brothers that's stage four
which you know we're working on the show
with mayan um oh where are you shooting
that
i believe at universal studios okay
because somebody bought
cbs radford which was the home of
um roseanne and seinfeld yeah and the
news and the union square i shot you
it's a legendary place right there on
radford and ventura
and uh got it see i think cbs owned it
and somebody just bought it for two
billion dollars for what
for you're not sure yet is it gonna be
studio uh yeah okay good but i don't
think cbs had a network and they were
running a lot i don't think they like
running the lot yeah because they're
kind of nice it's the older network and
they never need to stay focused well i
mean it's a beautiful lot to work on
cedric's over there and although the the
the warner brothers lot is my favorite
because of the gym and that old street
in central park that's still my favorite
well plus we have a plaque on the wall
our name is on the wall yep and stage so
we picked they took me around one time
with frank we went around on a golf cart
to show me the available stages and we
went in the back lot over there and i go
what's here and he goes not his [ __ ]
place man he goes you know everything
that's in here doesn't go like there's a
whole hierarchy of stages and good luck
and bad luck stages oh right so we're
driving around it's like no no
and then we went to the corner right
there on like bar hammer what turns into
olive and stage four
was where they did murphy brown for 10
years
so we were like [ __ ] they just got out
of there i said we'll take this one that
was great really that's why yeah well
the fact that we were close to george
clooney that didn't hurt george clooney
was right across where we see george
clooney all the time that was kind of
nice
i'm just kidding i'm just we saw a lot
of people walking through i saw
uh doug flutie i saw
the clint eastwood clint eastwood brad
pitt uh
jones brad pitt yeah hayek yep
oh that's right selma yeah i remember
seeing her
my go-to in my on the sitcom was i was
always saving myself for so much
from the beginning all through the whole
to the whole run of the show what's
someone going to think about what don't
worry about her
i can't believe i'm still sitting here
she's more interested in george clooney
i'm sure it wasn't just the name
no there was a hot corner over there oh
it was really
not george lopez it was no clooney it
was good
see my tv husband every day george
clooney he was doing ocean's 11 or
whatever production office there and i
remember his motorcycle
well there was one time that i don't
know it was a surreal moment he was at
the end coming around the corner and i
was coming from like central perk and he
was dressed in his tuxedo from from from
shooting and i was in my pajamas because
the first scene was in the pajamas i
don't know where i got the balls to say
this but i literally am like top of the
morning to you mr clooney and i yell it
down the stairs like ah miss marie how
are you doing and i'm thinking oh my god
what the [ __ ] am i doing i'm doing a bad
irish accent screaming at george clooney
and he came up and he gave me a hug and
we just chit-chatted a little bit and
then i went on the stage and i'm like
holy [ __ ] i just i just hugged him what
do you smell like i don't remember
anything it's so surreal george clooney
but i couldn't tell you you'd be jealous
you know what i was trying to do is i
was trying to get george clooney to come
down and have constance go george and
then have george clooney come to the
live audience that would have been crazy
that would have been what didn't work he
was good he wanted to do it it didn't
work out like he was like if i'm here
man you guys are shooting like i'll do
it i would have loved that would have
been so wonderful
mel gibson came by i was like i lost my
mind early on yeah he wanted directing a
sitcom or something
yeah he was there was he directed us to
come here i think he was going to or he
wanted to do research yeah he came in
there out of the to the he was there
almost all day watching yeah that was
like it was weird there was like a crowd
of people that followed him and it was
just our crew
big fans of his yeah this is pretty
crazy right now gibson this is when he
was normal see now you know the way i
feel
being around george
you
i mean these are your big time legendary
actors successful
that's that's the way i remember put
your [ __ ] tag back on
you ready for another beer
yes i know that was starting to talk
i love you so much
do you know do you know i think which
one of the first four shows
and
what moment
that i knew the show was gonna be on i
don't think it was gonna be on forever
but i thought you know i was always very
supportive when we did the puff and
stuff thing and we opened the curtain
and puffing stuff was in the backyard
yeah and like i had they asked me when
we were writing the show like who did
you like growing up you know do a thing
where
you
you tell your son you don't like
birthdays and he doesn't want a birthday
and then angie gives you the birthday he
always wanted us like uh
you know like hr puffing and stuff
they're like who h.r puff and stuff and
they they didn't know who they some did
but then some didn't and then they
looked it up and [ __ ]
they well you know what because if you
think about it up until then any time we
were latin latinx or whatever on tv it
was like they were we were this
stereotypical cliche we never got out of
east l.a we always were in the barrio we
always had
something some drama was happening
h.r puffin stuff
and witchy poo
and all those you know gosh i forgot
what's the name of the puppeteer
um
sydney crop crop yes sid croft and
company city mardi gras
but they don't equate
latinx people with
loving those things and you know i mean
i can trace my family back to 1850 in
america like technically i guess i'm
original people's or whatever they call
it um in new mexico um so yeah i i
didn't know that part of new mexico uh i
don't know wherever
the chirokawa apache tribe is from
shirakawa isles
no my mom did a dna thing and uh all the
way back my brother is 44 native
american
and so you know how latin family is like
yeah we came from spain and he was your
grandpa was full blooded apache well he
he was yeah i didn't realize that i've
got to have some i i don't have much
hair on me at all i got to believe him
native american partner well
we all i think we all are you know that
or
ends us roses
or you need to call your bad doctor and
find out what's happening with the hair
i had three of them come in my head at
the same time
i [ __ ] it up and get lasered psoriasis
or whatever
the uh uh is that what it's called
yeah the uh so but those days were they
were always fun weren't they oh my god
the early days were the first four and
then that was stressful i don't know if
you know but the first the one of the
episodes i think it was the was it the
pilot it was one of the first four
where was the backyard scene where we
had to throw that damn ball
and do it okay okay i had the worst
migraine oh
like so bad like the bright lights you
know like like you can't see like so
much pain
and it was like such a blessing because
something happened camera wise
lighting-wise i don't know what but i
literally was laying in my room it was
before we were going to shoot that scene
in the backyard and i have like a
freezing ice pack on my neck and i have
to turn all the lights off and i just
think if i can just lay here for 10
minutes the pain because it's hard to be
funny when you're in pain
and the scene we had to throw this ball
on the lines and get the laugh and the
timing was a nightmare so i remember
laying down
and i was thinking to myself dear god if
i can get through this i can get through
anything just let me make it through the
scene with this headache
and something happened to the lights in
the camera and i was there for 20
minutes by the time they were ready for
me again the headache was gone
and i shot the scene i didn't know that
i wanted to be
that scene ended up not being i don't
believe it
we're trying to get this [ __ ] ball
that had a balloon in it with a little
needle because bruce helpful like all
the little gimmicks yeah like that so we
were throwing it to each other it was on
a timer and it would blow up on my mom
yeah
and we never even knew it
we [ __ ] rehearsed with that thing for
all weeks oh my god it was a [ __ ]
ball around i i hated it i hated that i
had a timer where the with a balloon in
the ball and when the timer went up the
ball had a needle that would poke the
balloon and pop it
in new york but not in l.a
we worked with that thing all week so
the big deal was i think the end of the
the first cold open was that the mom
gets yeah yeah smacking that he liked
those long cold opens yeah right six
minutes four minutes yeah long one but
uh instead of short it was fun yeah that
was awesome that was that that show
changed my life
um i think it changed america
i think it did i really i really didn't
all kids and i'm still doing it yeah
it's still doing it because
it's on syndication i'm telling you i
was in vegas and then one of the shows
that i'd never seen before
was george talking about how he really
did steal
the president's speech yeah yeah yeah
yeah
that was when he came back for the
second season but because of our show i
think that um
i'm not gonna cry because you like it
when i cry and i'm not gonna cry i think
um there are many generations of latinx
kids who will grow up feeling included
in the american fabric on television and
that's not something you had or i had
and i didn't cry it's okay you know what
she makes fun of me for crying all the
time i really love it because she's not
smoking weed or drinking that's right
and is as good as a gift for her and she
doesn't like to cry around because i'll
keep it for another 20 years i know he
asks so many questions when i cry so i
shut it down hard but you know um
i think that uh
like growing up the way i did and spent
a lot of time alone and to be able to
leave a family sitcom behind yeah when i
didn't have those things growing up is
is great like all that stuff was
important too we were your family yeah
you know i think that's one of the
things is that it seemed genuine it
really did well we you know nothing
against you
because i've talked about finally in the
interviews before
like bolita myself
valente
emiliano like all of us had done shows
before
but george was the only one who who came
from a completely different walk of life
you know a genre and he was like the
gladiator on his own and was used to
doing it that way and we were like uh
okay the chemistry has got to work we've
got to be able to go back and forth he's
got to be able to banter with us and and
you know toss the ball back and receive
the ball the acting ball so um
i remember saying
that for you were one of the fastest
learners i had ever seen
like going from that where you're the
gladiator on your own you know the eye
bulge thing happened for you know but
you were you were not
afraid to tackle something that was
limiting
the show you were like well you know
what just just tell me [ __ ] tell me
when i'm doing it and i'll stop doing it
and that was something that did develop
for you know worked in your comedy but
you worked and you only had 19 kidney
function
i mean you add that on top of it it's
like a freaking miracle that you could
adapt and work that hard writing all day
on the set
and stopping the eye bulge yeah
yeah because in stand-up you could do
all that and then there everything was
just magnified yeah and they wrote about
it i think at the late time and they
were tight you know they were tight on
us you didn't have to read you know play
the whole stage yeah yeah and even all
that was tough for me like i didn't
[ __ ] never got
hired in a big part on a sitcom much
less
to have it all
be around folks around you yeah so on
the way
when i would leave and the guys were
relighting and setting up stuff for the
next day i would go in there with my
script and i would walk it like a
choreography yeah yeah in there and then
i ran into a few directors in there that
would say like what are you doing you
look up and they're up there looking at
shots and i would be walking to the
refrigerator or get coffee to back down
outside inside but we became your family
to support you is like for this to work
we all have to work together like that's
the only way that this is going to work
and we all knew
that this had never happened before
right and we were willing to bust our
ass and do whatever we had to do to make
it work and you can see it you can see
we're having a fun time there was some
great some we laughed i mean the show
was fun to do but
we laughed every day up oh yeah all the
time it was exhausting it was and but
thank
me too
the movement was after that because some
of the things i was laughing i was like
[ __ ] i can't be left i know we would
have you
just as just as the show was starting to
end more guys were going to hr yeah so
we left at the right time right right no
one ran into a guy going up and said
like where are you going hr that's not
all right we should wrap this up
you